SUNIL VEMURI: Hi,
I'm Sunil Vemuri,
and I can't wait
for the day when
I can talk to my watch and phone
like they do in the movies.
We're still a ways
away from that.
But the good news is we're
introducing a new API
in Android M that takes
us an important step
in that direction.
It's called voice
interaction API,
and it lets apps have
spoken dialogues with users.
I love listening to the
radio on my commute,
and the TuneIn app
gives me great choices.
OK Google, play music on TuneIn.
GOOGLE APP ASSISTANT:
Which genre would you
like to listen to?
SUNIL VEMURI: Classical.
GOOGLE APP ASSISTANT:
Playing classical.
SUNIL VEMURI: Handling
voice input can be complex.
Also I didn't just
give a command.
I had a conversation where
TuneIn asked me a question.
That conversation
part is what's new.
My colleague Barnaby and I will
show you how voice actions,
together with the
voice interaction API,
make it possible for you to
build conversational voice
experiences like TuneIn's.
Let's first look at a
brief system overview.
It starts with "OK Google"
also known as the hot word.
That triggers the assistant,
in this case, the Google App.
It starts listening to the user.
The speech-to-text,
cloud-based natural language,
and Knowledge
Graph work together
to determine what
should be done.
If it's an action, an
Android intent is triggered.
In our example, the intent
is handled by TuneIn.
Now Barnaby will tell you
how to do this in your app.
BARNABY JAMES: Hi,
I'm Barnaby James,
and I work on the Voice
Actions team at Google.
For some voice actions, it's
clear what an app should do.
What if the user's
command isn't clear,
and your app isn't
sure what to do,
and wants to ask
the user a question?
Or maybe it needs to
confirm something is safe.
The Voice Interaction API lets
your app focus on the questions
to ask the user
while Google handles
the speech-to-text,
microphone setup, and parsing
the responses.
Suppose your app wanted
to confirm with the user
before playing something
that may not be
suitable for younger listeners.
You would call the
voice interactor
and submit a request
for a confirmation
along with your prompt.
Google recognizes many
of the common ways
people give a
confirmation such as yes,
please do it, go
ahead, or make it so.
Or if you wanted to ask the
user to pick from a list
like TuneIn did, you'd
create an array of options
when you submit the voice
interaction request.
If your user speaks
something not on the list,
Google will take care
of reprompting for you.
OK Google, back to Sunil.
SUNIL VEMURI: Thanks, Barnaby.
There's one important
thing we left out.
How does a user launch
your app by voice?
For many of the common
things users do with voice,
such as searching, playing
music, setting alarms,
and so on, you should
use system voice actions.
Google recognizes when
a user asks for these
and fires the intent.
This is what TuneIn
used, and these
are documented on our website.
You can use these
right away, and we're
adding more all the time.
If system actions
don't fit your app,
we recently introduced
custom actions.
For example, I can say, "OK
Google, Shazam this song."
Here's the URL to learn more
about Custom Voice Sections.
Voice is a great way to
drive traffic to your app
and engage users.
Next, check out our CodeLab
and try out voice interaction.
Thanks and see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]